this pandemic has already left voting
officials working overtime
to get enough people to staff polling
places for the november election which
is now
32 days away now some big names have
joined the recruitment efforts
major garrett has been looking into the
challenges of voting during a pandemic
major good morning to you again good
morning again to you gail there is an
energetic effort you might even call it
frantic in some jurisdictions
to recruit a new generation of poll
workers to replace older ones who for
obvious
covet 19 related health issues are
stepping back
the catawba county library in newton
north carolina has been poll worker b
cheryl's election day home for more than
a decade but she will not be doing that
this year
no i will not to my sorrow cheryl's age
and underlying health conditions make
her vulnerable to coronavirus
i decided that my doctor would have a
voice
in it when i raised the question with
him his
face immediately said no how sad does
this make you
i shed many a tear it's the people i
miss the people
across the country election
administrators are racing to recruit
enough people to staff voting precincts
in a pandemic according to a 2018 study
more than half of poll workers are 61 or
older
putting many in an age group susceptible
to the virus
the bare minimum that we need is 37 000
just to open the polls on election day
frank larose is ohio's secretary of
state we wanted to have
that 50 percent extra as a reserve force
in case
there's a resurgence in the virus or
folks that choose not to
show up on november third and so really
what our target is is 55 000
that's meant creative recruiting tactics
like allowing 17 year old high school
seniors to serve as poll workers
encouraging businesses to give employees
election day off
and incentivizing charitable
organizations to pitch in
we got an opportunity there have been no
shortage of national appeals
we got to keep showing up at the polls
not just to cast our own vote but to
make sure
that others can too and former president
obama joined the cause this week
adding his voice to a poll worker
registration drive led
by nba royalty democracy doesn't work if
just a few people do it
one of the silver linings to this whole
pandemic experience as it relates to
elections administration is this will be
the year
that we recruited that whole new
generation of poll workers among that
new generation
is abby lublin a first-time poll worker
in durham north carolina
if we can't staff the polls it's too
easy of an excuse to close them
so i don't want to give any excuse for
voter suppression like many poll workers
this year lublin is taking training
classes online and she'll serve at this
precinct on duke's campus
during early voting and at this
elementary school on election day
i'm doing it because we need to and also
because i can
i am incredibly lucky um incredibly
privileged that i can do this and i
think it's a time where
we figure out whatever our capacity is
and do whatever we can
experts tell us the total number of new
poll workers needed this election year
nationwide is between 250 000 and
300 000. that is based on the assumption
that about 40 of previous poll workers
simply won't be there
and there are signs anthony that
recruitment is on pace the key is
distribution
in most states you have to work the
polls in the county where you live so a
surplus in one county
cannot be transferred to another that's
a problem that's a really big number
major but glad some of those folks are
stepping up thanks